[Musik]
zwei schriftsteller ein buch ein
ungewöhnliches unterfangen
sie bilde wie tschechow und najem wali
haben es unternommen
ihr stoff nichts weniger als die bibel
und der koran bei ihren streifzügen
entdecken sie figuren wie aber haben eva
maria oder jesus sie kommen in bibel und
koran vor
was ist gleich wo liegen die
unterschiede
warum sollten wir diese geschichten
heute noch lesen
lewitscharoff najem wali hat sich
willkommen der staat und religion hier
in einem studio in berlin wo sie
arbeitet zu hause sind lewitscharoff die
idee zu diesen streifzügen durch bibel
und koran hat magic v li gehabt was hat
sie dann inspiriert und motiviert damit
zu machen also ganz einfach ich fand den
keller sympathisch ja das ist ja schon
mal eine hauptvoraussetzung und wir
haben uns an einem abend lang sehr gut
unterhalten
das war sehr witzig und gut dann hat er
mir dann den vorschlag dann unterbreitet
etwas später und dann habe ich erst mal
sehr schnell ja gesagt aber war nicht
ich hätte es sah man rückzieher gemacht
wenn ich hatte noch kein buch von ihm
gelesen hab das dann getan und dann fand
ich den engel des südens an
hervorragenden roman und da dachte ich
vollen herzens das mache ich mit ihm und
den koran hatten sie vorher schon
gelesen ja aber vor langer zeit
lemperle was war bei ihnen der
entwicklung sowie jan de entstanden
ich meine struck diese idee seit lange
bei mir über vielleicht 15 20 jahren das
ist so ein buch über diese geschichten
mache weil ich festgestellt habe seitdem
ich auch in deutschland oder mich auch
durchfechten länder bewegen sich die
leute streiten
über religion kultur etc wobei alle
nicht wir sind dass ich die gleichen
geschichten von prophetin habe ich meine
die die berühmten propheten bewirken und
meine lebensgefährtin hat mir gesagt das
buch schreiben sie nie allein
du suchst eine person mit dem mit der
dusche halbs weil sonst ein wirt monaten
und da an einem abend waren ein
literatur festival nebelung festspiele
haben wir uns getroffen zufälligerweise
kannten wir uns nicht im gegenteil sie
bilde ich kannte ihre bücher ich mag
ihre bücher maria literatur sie hat
humor auf und ich war beim vielen weinen
sie war bei vielem wasser und saß neben
mir habe ich ihm gesagt für mich klar
dass ich weiß mit wem ich dieses buch
schreibe sie sagt da werde ich das buch
und da hab ich gesagt so und so sagte
okay dass das werden wir sehen
das ist das gebäude das über diese
streifzüge mich wird bevor wir jetzt
eintauchen und einzelne figuren
anschauen noch kurz interessieren
welches die brille ist oder welches die
feder ist mit der sie geschrieben haben
lewitscharoffs in der schriftstellerin
sie haben einen hintergrund
religionswissenschaften studiert und
sind ich sag mal in einem christlichen
kontext evangelisch aufgewachsen mit mit
welcher fehler haben sie hier
geschrieben naja also wirklich
religions- höhere in gewisser weise also
sagt man mich haben diese geschichten
immer fasziniert und es war für mich
eine wunderbare möglichkeit noch einmal
aus anderer perspektive auch mit seinen
augen den koran noch einmal anders zu
studieren oder zu lesen dann einfach
studierende sitze ist zu viel gesagt ja
und das hat mich einfach interessiert
zumal ja nun der koran in den letzten
jahren unglaublich an bedeutung gewonnen
hat und mich auch das gestört hatte so
viele sich zu wort melden die da gar
keine ahnung davon haben und warum es da
überhaupt gehen könnte also insofern
fand ich das was wir da etwas was
nationale davon geschlagen habe
eigentlich auch nicht ganz gute form
aufklärungs absicht wenn auch mit
literarischen hintergrund und das hat
mich doch fasziniert ich halte es auch
für nicht aber mit einer gewissen
freiheitlich
natürlich im wallis sind haben
germanistik studiert sind auch
schriftsteller
sie sind im irak aufgewachsen 1980 dann
nach deutschland gekommen wir haben sie
es angegangen
also ich bin reingegangen als die tat
also ich habe mir alle geschichten
betrachtet als sagen wir mal wie man ein
germanistik literatur studiert oder
literaturwissenschaft studiert und diese
prophetin geschichten die auch in meiner
umgebung in eine muslimische umgebung
bin ich aufgewachsen aber in einer zeit
war ich aufgewachsen wo die religion
nicht wie heute politisch ist es war
eine volks islam also das heißt hier der
betet für sich aber kein zwang auf die
anderen und und durch dieser
freizügigkeit kam es zu diesen
geschichten als geschichten weil die
großmutter hat auch diese geschichten
erzählt der großvater hat die
geschichten erzählt natürlich mit mit
sie haben was dazu erzählt nicht aus dem
koran die reaktion dann haben sie die
geschichte anders ausgelegt und dann
später ich habe dir als literarische
texte betrachtet so war ich auch frei in
dem sinne frei von religion von gläubig
bin auch keine gläubige bin ich an den
geschichten ganz frei ist auch
interessant ja nur einfach dass wir
verstehen und das publikum versteht mit
mit welcher intention und mit welchen
voraussetzungen sie dahinter gegangen
sind legen wir los
also wir haben hier eine darstellung war
mit und schon einige der figuren
versammelt sie haben es angedeutet
wir sehen abraham wir sehen auch jesus
in der darstellung wurden nur 6 fangen
wir mal mit der apra hamm figur an es
heißt immer der abraham wäre der
stammvater von judentum christentum und
islam
inwiefern stampfer apa na das ist ja
tatsächlich für alle drei religionen
weil gut er ist ja in der jüdischen
bibel zunächst madrid als erster auf
dann ist er hat er zwei söhne und der
eine sohn wird dir nachher der begründer
des islam der kommt er dann auf diese
ganz andere neue religion zu wandert er
zu und die christen beziehen sich
selbstverständlich auch auf diese
geschichte ist er ja eine grundlegende
geschichte der bibel von der alles sehr
viel abzweig ja also insofern ist es
klar dass alle drei religionen daran
schmeißen wenn man so will er also ist
am pegel weil das so stand in dem alten
testament
also weil thomas ältester religion
natürlich hat die figur oberarmen zuerst
und dann kamen die andere religion haben
kampf anzusagen ausgelegt oder
abgeschrieben oder plagiat kann man
erzählen wie man will
das ist eine interessante figur weil er
konnte alle diese drei religionen
einigen indem er an einem gott geglaubt
hat also er hat nicht an gott geglaubt
da sind die drei regionen jetzt einig
abraham war der erste der für nur für
einen gott als trainer
timo notate monotheismus und deshalb
akzeptieren sie ihm und später natürlich
region versucht die geschichte anders
interpretieren damit wie religion sagt
dass meine spezialität
deshalb also bei judentum bei christen
es opfert seine eltern so genau ich
möchte auch gleich damit ein ergebnis
eine verstörende geschichte oder
vielleicht an einem beispiel mal zu
zeigen
wir haben ja auch eine darstellung ist
eine flämische malerei aus dem 17ten
jahrhundert eben es zeigt die sogenannte
bindung also die geplante opfer bat die
beiden söhne
also ist mal wo dann die linie eben in
den islam geht und wisag seinen sag mal
sohn von der sarah den er jetzt opfern
soll
wir haben sie diese gibt diese
geschichte in der bibel gelegt
zunächst einmal habe ich sie gelesen wie
sie landläufig gelesen werden dass also
die abraham tatsächlich willig war dem
sohn zu opfern
und dass er durch diesen großartigen
gottes gehorsam auch zu dem stammvater
hat werden können als der er nachher
erhöht wurde aber in späteren jahren
habe ich eben jüdischen jüdische
auslegung zur kenntnis genommen die ganz
interessant sind weil sie davon absehen
die sehen eigentlich das ist eine
untergeordnete linie auch jüdischen
ausleben muss man schon sagen aber sie
ist stark die
mich hat daran interessiert die sagen
nein abraham ist einer teuflischen in
situation zum opfer gefallen niemals
würde gott befehl an den befehl geben
dass man den den stammhalter und den
wichtigen sohn schlachtet ja kommen und
das ist spannend finde ich also sofort
hat mich die geschichte dann später hier
nochmal ganz neue interessieren
im koran wie wird die geschichte im chor
und anerkennen dass wir dann erzählt
erstmal erstmal sollte geopfert werden
nicht aber es hat kommt vor auch also
dann der sohn von haga ich muss es noch
nachtragen
vielleicht ist nicht für alle ganz klar
oder dass er der wollte eigentlich gerne
ein kind haben der bahn hat aber lange
keins bekommen und von seiner frau sarah
also nicht hat dann von seiner markt
also seinen mit einem von ihm seiner
frau
sie schickt ihn dann so hager und von
ihr bekommt er dann die spd hat sich als
geschenke kriegt im moment von dem
verein als geschenk wieder er war sarah
eben ja schon da kommt also zwischen den
beiden frauen deshalb kommt dem islam
sagt marina s bahn wird geopfert und
dann kommt von gott ein
wetter oder lamm als ersatz also ich
habe diese geschichte nicht nur gelesen
haben wir diese geschichte gelebt weil
dieses foto anders foto hängt bei uns im
wohnzimmer an meinem zuhause als kind so
alsbald die welt habe ich dieses bild
gesehen was wurde in den erklärt ja das
habe ich sage es ist also wenn ich
großvater der vater gefragt haben sagt
ja das ist sie haben auf der
gehorsamkeit des sonne also wie der sohn
dem vater unterlegen so und als
gehorsamkeit nicht auf dem fall von
opferung also betont sondern weil es mal
also auch so wohl auch es hat sie haben
das zugebilligt der sie geopfert werden
also abraham hat sie gefragt so beim für
ismael im koran sowie sein vater hat ihn
gefragt gott will von mir ein opfer und
es mag ja das mache ich das seine
unterschied zu bieten
natürlich aber eher weil in der bibel
zieht er los der vororte ohne dem sohn
zu sagen war da frage was er jetzt
vorhaben deshalb sagte ich jetzt region
muss anders auslegen
aber in einem punkt filme sind die drei
religionen sind einig in dem fall einen
sündenbock zu finden also bis heute
haben wir dieses fahren und da gibt es
also viele tablette als es muss geopfert
werden wir für gott so wir haben auch
sogar eine geschichte die jetzt
vorletzter woche die lieferung dieser
prozession verhassten immer präsent für
die schiiten ist er sehr heilig und in
der prozession soll jemand ein vater
sein sohn
geopfert hat für hessen das ist wahnsinn
ist das hobby nie in geschichte und der
geschichte des landes gehabt wo wir weit
jetzt man mit dieser opferung geschichte
weitergeht
also ich habe einen christlichen
hintergrund ich komme aus der theologie
um mich hat diese geschichte immer
zutiefst genervt weil ich mir einfach
diesen schlechter gott der sowas
verlangen soll von einem pfad konnte mir
nicht vorstellen und ich war in dieser
minute dann wo ich eben eine jüdische
interpretation von ich weiß nicht mehr
wegen schriftsteller gelesen habe war
ich einfach dann versöhnt weil er sagt
es geht in der geschichte um den
religiösen waren dieser abraham
unterliegt einem religiösen wahn der
meint im ernst gott würde das von ihm
verlangen aber ist zeigt die geschichte
wo leute die überdreht religiös sind am
ende landen und auch das natürlich jetzt
noch einmal egal wie man die geschichte
interpretiert obmann wert legt auf den
gottes gehorsam aber hans oder sagt es
ist eine dämonische einflüsterungen
entscheidend ist aber trotz allem das
ist opfer nicht stattfindet das ist und
damit ist ja trotz allem egal wie man es
interpretiert zunächst einmal gesagt ein
menschenopfer darf nicht stattfinden das
ist eine riesengeschichte besonders
innerhalb dieser altorientalischen welt
wo menschen opfer ja noch ziemlich gang
und gäbe waren rundherum also insofern
ist es eine dramatische geschichte sagen
wir mal man kann auch sagen so
zivilisierung der menschheit zumindest
in dieser region also das geht jetzt
nicht mehr so einfach aber ich habe es
gibt ich habe gehört es gibt auch eine
islamischen überlieferung also nicht im
koran sondern in der islamischen
überlieferungen die meinung oder die
überlegung dass eben abraham damit er
endlich einen nachkommen bekommt gesagt
hätte dafür gebe ich dir zu opfern was
mir in dieser welt am liebsten ist und
jetzt er hat sozusagen zu viel
versprochen muss er auch das praktisch
einlösen dass seine warnung sozusagen
nicht etwas zu versprechen was man nicht
einhalten könne
auch wenn ein teil haben sie uns
unterschlagen diese ämter bretter ja das
ist für mich ist es nicht wichtig diese
im pokal ja weil allein also wäre opfert
man beide also ist mein oder weil es
machen kam nach weshalb er hätte auch
mit deshalb in diesem fall hatte er mit
sh anfangen soll mit dem aufforderung
dann war die geschichte mit wann er es
geht um sein versprechen einzuhalten
denn hatte abraham mit ist hart und der
tat anfangen weil der aktion schon ist
hat mit kommen aber deshalb habe ich
diese geschichte wir haben viele details
auch nicht im buch erzählt also wir
haben die wichtigen details haben aber
sie haben ja wenn sie sie wären atheist
oder wie können sie denn sie haben das
als kind offenbar diese darstellung dann
oft gesehen können sie der geschichte
heute noch etwas abgewinnen
die geschichte ist eine geschichte alle
geschichten die erzählt werden für mich
war solange sie erzählt wird weil die
menschen sie wahrnehmen
und es gibt menschen die die
praktizieren sogar ich werde auch sogar
machen werden wie auf erfahrungen weiter
gehen
ich werde eine provozierende these her
vorlegen also jesus christus opferung
von sich selbst allein ist die höhepunkt
von dieser opfern wird der sohn gottes
und er macht das freiwillig hätte am
kreuz und kreuz lässt sich selber ein
großes an sich ist die höchste stufe von
dieser opfer sie lesen dass dann in
dieser linie ist sozusagen weiter bei
jetzt von nazareth gut dazu muss ich
sagen es gibt ungefähr 13
interpretationen schon neuer erst einmal
wie der tod von jesus interpretiert wird
und ich halte von dieser sagt
offiziellen gar nichts aber gut
vielleicht kommen wir noch dazu woche
ist klar auch nichtmuslime wissen sie
dass dem koran steht jesus wird nicht
genau dass ihre im gegenteil dass das
gefällt mir sehr
es ist allerdings auch reparieren weil
der tod jesu am kreuz sein einziger
geschichte die historisch wirklich außer
biblis belegt ist oder aber wie gesagt
ich wollte nur eine sache sagen für mich
ist nicht wichtig ob jetzt die
dieser geschichten real waren oder nicht
weil es gibt auch keine beweise ist
abraham
das haben sie auch schon gelegt am
anfang an sie hatten das projekt
herangegangen sehen ich hatte einfach
noch interessiert koran waren denn
dieses stichwort dieses buch bei uns so
ins bewusstsein gekommen ist wie immer
bei uns ins archiv gegangen beim
fernsehen ab festgestellt wirklich koran
koran gibt es das erste mal im jahr 1991
sie sehen gleich warum der koran
entstanden ist er im siebten jahrhundert
damals brachte mohamed nach einer
offenbarung die weisungen gottes zu
papier knapp eine milliarde moslems
leben seither danach seit vergangenem
herbst wird bei uns der koran vermehrt
verkauft und auch andere bücher
das sind in erster linie spielte dann
auch über die islamische welt also die
religion die islamische rekord bei
spielsweise und seit januar verstärkt
dann bücher zum aktuellen konflikt ich
möchte da wären das buch von arnold
hottinger und dann das weniger von
scholl latour schwert des islam und öl
ins feuer vom team auch in zürichs
moschee hat man festgestellt dass das
interesse am koran steigt fragt sich nur
ob es genügt ohne schulung den koran zu
lesen um die islamische denkweise und
mentalität besser zu verstehen wir sind
sicher wenn man koran liest könnte man
diese missverständnisse entfernen
die problem ist extra in europa die
leute die wissen mehrere leute die
wissen nichts über den islam und ungarn
und die haben nicht nur von ungelernten
leute über islam gehört oder gelernt
bleibt nur zu hoffen dass durch die
lektüre des korans tatsächlich einige
missverständnisse beseitigt und nicht
neue geschaffen werden
ja missverständnisse beseitigen war das
auch das anliegen ihres projektes ich
würde sagen auf jeden fall entspannungs
bemühungen in jeder hinsicht also
einfach eine jetzt nicht saniert
religiös gestimmte wissensvermittlung
sondern eine die ein bisschen anders
daherkommt die sowohl auf die
schönheiten des korans rücksicht nehmen
das ja wirklich auch eine eine
wunderbare poetische schrift ist als
auch auf die schlagkräftigen geschichten
der bibel die meines erachtens gehören
diese bücher doch zu einem wichtigen
erbitterter zumindest oder westlich
orientierten menschheit bis hinein in
den orientalischen ländern und darüber
noch gar nichts zu wissen ist meines
erachtens einfach depot haben
vielleicht darf ich eine winzige sache
nur anmerken meine begegnung im koran
war recht früh ich habe nämlich mal also
war ich 22 im museum von darlehen bei
einer ausstellung mitgearbeitet für
islamische kunst und da habe ich zum
ersten mal hatten wir aus dem
metropolitan museum wunderbare koran
schriften und ich war entzückt durfte
mit weißen handschuhen durfte ich diese
diese diese großartigen schriften
durchblättern und bücher und so weiter
und ich war hin und weg gerissen von der
schönheit der schrift
moment ich der sache und so weiter
traumhaft schön also muss wirklich sagen
es war meine erste begehung tief
berührend dass man aus einer anderen
zeitung heraus eine solche schönheit
auch in der schrift bewirken kann ja
große klasse das hören sie natürlich
gerne
für viele hat aber der koran seit den
attentaten vom september 2001 vielleicht
nicht mehr so einen guten ruf
das ist richtig für das auch nicht gern
also das ist das wenn man die schrift
beschreibt das eine realität die schrift
ist schön und man muss das auch erklären
kommt daher weil das es gibt ein bild
verbot deshalb haben die künstler die
zeichner als ersatz haben ihrer kunst
gezeigt in den schriften
auch eine kamera oder so in den
schriften sieht man manchmal für guten
von menschen weil sie über sie
normalerweise nicht malen dürfen weil
man kann nicht einen menschen mal darf
man nicht das ist ja ein bild der
verbohrten islam und das ist der ersatz
im schritt deshalb da hakt ist das
gekommen das ist eine realität aber
natürlich der islam heute zu tage es ist
verruf auch einfach eine gründen weil
religionen überhaupt wo der
kommunikation überhaupt hängt von dem
empfänger ab und islam ist wie man
interpretiert und christentum wie man
interpretiert judentum wie man
interpretiert bei der anderen person und
daraus wirklich ärger bei der
schwierigkeit oder das ist die
schwierigkeit wir haben ja gesehen bei
abraham diese geschichten zu
interpretieren das ist nicht ganz ohne
diese schriften ich finde sie nicht so
leicht zugänglich wäre das nicht besser
zu sagen finger weg
also das finde ich jetzt generell nicht
auch wenn es schwierig ist sich ein
bisschen zu bemühen das hat immer noch
geistige vorteile allerdings natürlich
und da sehen wir uns beide sicher einige
male und ich dass wir sagen also es geht
auch um das selbstverständlich um das
wissen mit toleranz verbundenen
selbstverständlich ich bin zwar ein
bisschen religiöser als er aber das
heißt noch lange nicht dass ich dass
irgendjemandem aufzwingen möchte ja das
heißt also die freiheit der
freiheitsgedanke war für uns beide
sicher maßgeblich bei diesem gestaltung
des buches brauchen wir doch in die
nächsten figuren ein gehen wir zum
anfahren fangen wir bei adam und eva an
wir haben hier eine miniatur aus dem
islamischen raum und wir haben dann auch
noch nette ausstellung von lucas cranach
dem älteren ja aus dem sechzehnten
jahrhundert die islamische darstellung
ist natürlich aus den dreizehnten
jahrhundert viel älter jetzt
interessiert mich schon oder adam und
eva das ist für unseren kontext klar
gehört an den anfang in die bibel
wie kommen sie in koran vor ja sie
kommen ja die bahn im paradies die
beiden zuerst und was ich auch als ich
zuerst wollte ich war wollten wir über
etwas schreiben aber kam wie groß meine
klasse aber durch als ich damit
angefangen habe habe ich entdeckt dass
im koran niemals eva schuld hat an dass
die frucht der rosen die hand amtes zu
tun im gegenteil er hat sie eingeführt
also er hat sie verführt und deshalb
gott sagt ihm direkt du hast auch du an
deiner frau damit reingelegt also an
sich hat sie damit nichts zu tun was
viele muslime ebit ist nicht wissen dass
auch interessant weil da sieht man der
unterschied zwischen traditionen in
einer gesellschaft und die religion
selbst wenn nicht dieses will sie auch
werde ich auch was dazu sagen aber
zuerst würde sagen die tradition eine
patriarchalische gesellschaft gibt immer
frauen schuld deshalb wird im koran
steht eva nicht schuld aber keiner sagen
dass sagt immer der prophet hat gesagt
alle vor seite war sind alle frauen
schuld und hier eine sehr vitale schon
stark wie sie in einem bild sie haben
gesagt ist es islamische illustration
das ist einsicht fertig bei der perser
bilde und malerei war legitim
das ist sich von 13 jahrhundert das hat
das bilderverbot da war ja aber sie
finde niemals in arabischer schrift dem
und älter wird und da sehe ich will ich
nur sagen wer ist jetzt muslim sind die
perser oder die araber das ist es ist ja
da können wir jetzt streiten können wir
alles mal das will sie sagen aber
tradition bei den persern bilder waren
verboten ja das ist ein ganz wichtiger
punkt oder sie muss angemessen
nichtmuslime muslimen es gibt
verschiedene traditionen ja mit
verschiedene auslegungen deshalb
befinden jetzt in pakistan indien in
china in alles sind
ferner gibt es bilder von adam und eva
von propheten von allem aber nicht
witzig ist ich habe diesen damals beide
auch schon natürlich auch bilder aus von
illustrationen gesehen aber lustig war
der prophet mohammed war immer mit zug
mit torwart mit soja oder mit dem meist
häuschen also sozusagen war dass andere
etwas verhüllt
sie haben aber zeigt er läuft mir weil
ich ein kleines erklärung
aber die haben gar kein sekt lecker da
ist natürlich interessant also noch
einmal zur deutung was eva getan
tatsächlich ist sie im koran sehr viel
unschuldiger im in der liebe ist stark
massiv auf ihre schuld natürlich gesetzt
nur wenn man sie natürlich modern
interpretiert und das kann man ja tun
ist eigentlich die eva so etwas wie
eigentlich die unsere fortschrittsmotor
wenn man so will ja also sie sorgt ja
dafür dass ihm aufgrund ihrer neugier
oder damit dass der mensch von etwas
schmausen kann was eigentlich gott
gebührt und damit natürlich auch
hellsichtiger wird für neugierde
neugieriger hellsichtiger mehr wissen
sich aneignen kann die erde auch ganz
anderen beackern und hole sich untertan
machen kann ich sprechen jetzt von der
geschichte wo sie vom apfel reicht vom
baum der erkenntnis da sollte sie
eigentlich nicht ran an diesem morgen
also das heißt also sie übertritte ein
klares verbot aber zugunsten der leyen
gehe generell neugier ist natürlich auch
die wissenschafts tragen da kann man gar
nicht leugnen also neugierige menschen
die tun ja was im guten wie im bösen
das ist ein doppeltes erbe das wissen
wir alle mittlerweile das also aber das
stand aber wir können heute nicht mehr
den stand der unwissenden unschuld zu
verherrlichen das dürfte uns doch allen
schwer fahren insofern würde ich heute
eher sagen wenn man die geschichte
vorträgt das ist ja eine parabel und das
ist keine nicht wirklichkeit gewesen
sein auch eine parabel schöne würde man
eher durch der frau zubilligen dass sie
ihre neugierige nase ausgestreckt hat
und eigentlich für so etwas wie das
aufkommen
interessant also sie kritisieren
eigentlich seine wörtliche auslegung
oder nein ich weiß bin ich fand schon
erstaunlich als nicht gläubiger sagen
sie hier einen punkt wenigstens ein
punkt geht also an den koran eben
urheber der ersten zehner ist im koran
nicht die frau ist sünde ist der erste
unterricht geben ob es nicht allen
leuten gefällt der mann ja also es ist
ich habe den koran als literarischen
text behandelt und da sage ich betrachte
ich hin als tragischen tag nicht als
religiöse text und das haben sage ich es
1 1 punkt mindestens in dieser sache in
dieser geschichte ein punkt aber wie ist
gesagt habe kein mensch bis heute hat
das gesagt vor mir in keiner in
islamischen ländern kein arabisches land
sagt man kennt man diese geschichte und
wenn ich diese geschichte erzähle wird
man mir sagen ich spinne
obwohl diese geschichte wurde also man
kann das belegen im koran er spannend
oder die unterschiede reiten wird sehr
interessant das ist interessant werden
in bezug auf die religions- regierungen
und auch auslegungs gemeinsame
auslegungs start sind hier kann man das
jetzt auch kritisch anmerkten sie sagen
ja in ihrem beitrag eva wurde aus der
des schlafenden adams rippe erschaffen
und eigentlich muss ich sagen sie
transportieren hier eine wörtliche
übersetzung wir wissen heute aus der
neueren bibel forschung dass es da gar
nicht um adam sondern um den ersten
menschen also nicht abermals mann
sondern in der neueren übersetzung sagt
man mensch das heißt es ist eigentlich
die ehe war aus der mensch und nicht aus
dem man es ein ganz altes missverstanden
ist eigentlich was den leuten endlich
mal erklären müsste passiert für ihren
kontext getan haben aber das nicht eva
aus dem mann erschaffen wird sondern
eigentlich aus dem menschen adam ist
eigentlich der erdlinge die gefa wird
aus der erde eben wieder hoam erschaffen
das gute hinweise nehme ihnen gerne zur
kenntnis
was ist der erster mensch die erde
es gibt zwei schöpfungsbericht ganz
wichtig in der hebräischen bibel der
zweite schöpfungsbericht sachsen noch
schön
er schuf mann und frau als abbild gottes
und damit ganz wichtig die bibel ist
eine in der zeit revolutionär im
gegensatz zu dem was vorher aber in
diesem punkt und hebt mann und frau auf
die gleiche ebene ist in dem sinn großer
fortschritt und als ebenbild als abbild
gottes ja und dann gehen wir noch zu
einer weiteren figur oder wie waren die
reaktionen eigentlich auf vier projekt
also bisher so gut
keine anstöße erregt also die die etwas
fanatisierten muslime nehmen ist sowieso
nicht zur kenntnis sie lesen ja sowas
nicht also insofern gab es von der seite
schon mal gar nicht
und ist das so auch bei ihnen
er hat bis jetzt habe ich keine negative
reaktion auf meinem buch also ich habe
negative reaktionen auf meine person
auch meine kaffeetasse auf meine bücher
überhaupt ist die clique ich oft e-mails
oder auf facebook und die hass
paraden gegen mich laufen immer aber
nicht unbedingt mit diesem buch zusammen
das ist auch mit anderen bücher weil ich
religion ist ein thema von meinen roman
von meinem bücher und ich behandele
immer tabu sind man da ja und er hat ein
wunderbares neues buch geschrieben über
eine kann er seine frau die in saudi
arabien ihren weg geht das gefällt ja
vielen sicher auch nicht also der jahre
schon auf der angriffsfläche
das ist ein wunderbar es ist ein sehr
schönes buch und da da hat er ja ein
richtiges fenster geöffnet ja ja das war
parallel dafür also ein roman
heizstrahler sind jetzt natürlich hat
viel jetzt anfeindungen gekriegt und
seit der offiziellen presse auch ein
höherer gestimmt weil die presse der
alfabet liegt in den händen von den
golfstaaten saudi arabien deshalb hat
man den roman angegriffen dass genau das
heißt aber ebenso wie sie es erlebt
haben in ihre kindheit war religion habe
ich nicht so ein riesiges thema im irak
war mehr der nationalismus ein thema
oder ja das war ja das war islam also
ich habe einfach mein vater mein
großvater mein vater ein gebet mal
großvater war ein normaler bauer hat
gebetet immer in der ecke eines immer
allein
und wenn man ihn gefragt hat warum
würdest du allein sagte weil ich mit
kurz sprechen so etwas erwartet
es gab keine moscheen es gab keine
maschinen wie heute dass die leute in
massen auf der straße beten gab es nicht
sie haben ja gesagt bei ihnen
schließlich etwas vor religiöser noch
als er beißt aber ich habe es als kind
wunderbar erlebt und es hängt hängt an
ich hatte eine wahnsinnig lebens
wirkliche sehr fromme großmutter der
borussia und aber eine gute seele also
wirklich guter mensch glaubwürdig guter
mensch und wenn sie von so jemandem die
geschichten aus der bibel schön erzählt
bekommen sie hat auch noch eine tolle
stimme gehabt sagt wunderbar gesungen
kirchenlieder
das ist für mich unvergessen weil es
eben mit dieser liebenswürdigkeit
verbunden war und eben nicht ohne diesen
draw es war ohne den drohenden
aggressiven beiklang also ich hab mich
als kind zum beispiel immer sehr sehr
brav natürlich auch auf anleitung der
großmutter meine meine kleidungsstücke
ganz brav über den stuhl gehängt damit
jesus nachts kommen kann und guckt dass
ich alles ordentlich aufgeräumt habe
aber das war keine kein fluch und keine
strafe habe ich dann gemacht das heißt
also ich war ein volksnahes kind
religions- höre ich bis ins mark und ich
weiß nicht warum ich das verleugnen soll
ja das hat ja auch meine spätere
hinwendung immerhin zur
religionswissenschaft und zur bibel
lektüre irgendwann mal auch koran
lektüre
das ist ja ein schönes erbe also in
bezug auf großeltern also die iraker 10
1 wird es ein makabrer witz teil über
drei generationen der großvater sitzt
und die kinder machen sich
bereit da sie in die moschee gehen abend
weil sie das gebet gehört haben und der
sohn also der vater von den kindern
dreht sich ein
er kippt dann dreht sich so und der
großvater sagt zu sein so und schämst du
dich deine kinder gehen eine moschee und
was machst du doubs sagte da siehst du
den unterschied von der erziehung
es erklärt erklärt wie drei generationen
wie die ärzte nichts geändert hat
sie können gut miteinander ich hab mich
etwas gewundert dass die kapitel stehen
nebeneinander
es ist nicht eigentlich ein dialog den
sie hier führen sondern sie schreiben ja
aus ihrer sicht über diese figuren gab
es dazwischen ihn noch mehr
das lag an zwei dingen zum einen konnte
najem wali sehr viel früher loslegen als
ich also ein gutes halbes jahr vor
und er hatte danach keine zeit und ich
musste warten weil ich etwas fertig mal
das heißt also er hat eigentlich im
vorlauf schon gearbeitet gehabt es ging
gar nicht anders das heißt wir konnten
jetzt nicht sagen wir uns bei jeder
geschichte treffen aber organe da in
berlin unbedingt so zu sagen er hat
einfach mal loslegen müssen und das kam
ich denke wenn wir in berlin beide zur
gleichen zeit los gelegt hätten wir uns
immer mal bei jeder geschichte noch
einmal getroffen und das bisher
abgeschlagen das war ein bisschen der
zeit geschuldet die in der wir schrieben
aber ich als nachklapp hat dann halt
immer bisher versucht ein kleines
bisschen rücksicht zu nehmen und
zumindest mal so klein ist ruhig sehr
über zu genau zu dem was er schon
geschrieben hatte aber ich fand das auch
in ordnung so fand ich dass sibylle
anders herangegangen ist ja an an die
geschichten und ich anders herangegangen
wenn aber wie gesagt ein es hat uns von
anfang an dieser brücken aufzubauen
da haben wir immer im auge behalten und
und das ist wirklich wegen zeitmangel
aber wir haben uns geeignet auch die
figuren meine figuren immer noch das ist
ja das ist eine geschichte hier
wahnsinnig gut gefällt dass der prophet
das eine
mission verweigert und er sollte ein
minivan mit den leuten schimpfen und
mehr geht nicht dahin geht auf ein
schiff von muss dann über bord weil man
merkt eben das ist der kerl wegen dem
ihr der sturm losbricht da wird von
einem großen war verschlungen nach drei
tagen und drei nächten ausgesprochen am
schluss geht er dann eben doch noch nach
ninive ungefähr so oder ist die
geschichte an der sohn habe jedoch
weiter und die da der story finde ich an
der geschichte auf der einen seite ist
ein feigling er hat ja also erwählt des
propheten amt nicht übernehmen
aber sobald er gerettet wird ist ein an
land gespült wird und wieder nach dem
event geht wird er plötzlich ein
hardcore
naja da möchte dass gott jetzt aber
wirklich die stadt vernichtet irgendwie
so jan also ausgerechnet der feigling
und das ist eine typische menschliche
geschichte die feigling ist in dem ich
über die dann irgendwie das großen
strafgericht wären ein zeigefinger
heininger ganz hoch lebens machen und
dann ist aber so witzig finde ich wie
gott ihn noch einmal straft das ist
wirklich das finde ich richtig witzig
als erhob dann da ist er wüste und an
eine riesige pflanze gespendet im
schatten und innerhalb von praktisch
sekunden schmucke zusammen zu dix und
und gott zeigt eben damit also wer hier
der machthaber ist und wer hier gebiet
ich finde die geschichte witzig und sie
wer wird da verschoben und nene wird
verschont und es ist eine der witzigsten
geschichten in der bibel die hat
wirklich ein bisschen topologischen
gießen biglia den koran berichtet ja und
so ähnlich und konnte eigentlich aktuell
ich also interessant für mich auch wird
sich außerhalb des textes weil männer
und mehr
ich habe das gemessen die sind über 1500
kilometer wie hat er das geschafft sich
getrennt
wir haben eher zum meer und am land
nämlich eine rassismus wo es war ja das
ist im irak und mittelmeer
es gibt geschichten die sagen er war bis
gibraltar mit dem schiff oder bei yahoo
also wie hat 1000 1500 kilometer
erzählte uns werden die bibel noch der
koran wie es dazu gekommen nur aus
letztlich um die ecke gegangen ist ich
werde eine rauchen zigaretten komme
zurück für mich die geschichte so
ähnlich er hat seit den sprung er hat
mit anderer frau geschlafen er muss als
seiner frau an das erzähle gesagt ich
war drei tage im bauch von wahlweise es
gibt keine logik aber das heißt
positiven ausgang der geschichte ist so
beschrieben oder ja so beschrieben mit
einer also das ist mit diesem nicht
feigheit dabei mit ungeduld im command
mehr dass er ungeduldig war und das
bezieht sich auf mohammed selbst also
die meisten geschichten die habe ich
auch ein bischen die meisten geschichten
wurden interpretiert so nach dem maß von
mohammed als person deshalb abraham
kommt sehr sehr wichtig im koran damit
muhammad sagt nach abraham nur ich komme
also hat so sein leben auch beschrieben
wie sein leben auf und bei bei dieser
geschichte auch also mehr
er war nicht er war ungeduldig er hat
nicht gewartet er wollte abhauen aber
nicht aus feigheit sondern aus ungeduld
weil er hat darauf gewartet er hat
gewartet dass gott was tut und wort hat
das nicht gemacht und deshalb ist er
ungeduldig abgehauen und mohammed hat so
eine kleine phase gehabt auf die
offenbarung gewartet sagt man erzählt
man nun die offenbarung hatten sich
verweigert drei vier tage das ist eine
interpretation es gibt andere
interpretationen wo man sagt derjenige
der wie sein vater wie sein vater
vaterfigur der cuisine von seiner erster
frau kredite er war ein priester christ
und der hat ihm inspirierten diesen
geschichten und er war tot und nach dem
tod von diesem
ist der nach seinem tod kam kein kein
azzurra
es war eine sehr harte eine black out
phase und weshalb kam danach ist diese
also in diesem kontext stellen sie eine
geschichte mit eben ungeduld mit
ungeduld was haben sie noch sonst so aus
dieser geschichte rausgezogen
psychologisch diesen biblischen
geschichten und speziellen der immer
noch hin und herschwanken care also zb
erstmals feigling der abhaut dann auf
dem schiff später dann wo er aber dann
nicht feige ist auf dem schiff selber
wiederum befiehlt er ja oder sagte er
den matrosen werft mich ins meer dann
aber dass sturm einfach nicht aufhört ja
genau also das heißt da ist ja
eigentlich sehr mutig wiederum oder in
dem mit seinem schicksal ins auge sehen
ja das heißt dass dollar an diesen
biblischen figuren ist einfach immer ist
die schwank maße die sie entdecken also
von feiglingen zum fliegenden zu
ermutigen selbst opfer und dann wiederum
zurückkehrt wieder zum zornigen
zeigefinger menschen und mir mir gefällt
es ja diese das weil weil diese
charaktere in der bibel die sind ja
niemals eindimensionalen nur wenige
figuren sind wirklich eindimensional und
das ist ich finde das ist einfach die
große story der menschheitsgeschichte
für den westlichen raum weil bei in
früher zeit ein unglaublich
differenziertes menschen bildschirm
aufgebaut wurde
ganz anders als in den mythologischen
strukturen runden ringsherum ja sie
haben in der antiken mythologie sei es
griechenland sei es gibt haben sie zum
beispiel niemals die würde der menschen
die kommen ja gar nicht vor das heißt
sie haben auch in hd ist gar nichts
verloren das heißt also die bibel ist
schon irrsinnig gut dass sie ein
differenziertes psychologisches
verständnis aufhört von verschiedenen
figuren und hauptsächlich aber auch
leute die nichts zu sagen haben in der
welt würdigt auf eine ganz andere weise
also das ist egal ob man religiös
gestimmt ist oder nicht das ist schon
eine das ist also wirklich eine
ein riesen pfund dieser diese diese
biblischen geschichten und da
unterscheiden wir uns da unterscheiden
wir uns weil die alte mythologie für
mich selbst das alte testament ist eine
abschreibung von alten von alten
mythologien gerade fortschritt oft auch
aus ja ich nehme wir nehmen mal die
geschichte von der geburt von der wie
heißt das von dauer und die sintflut ist
im sinne der sintflut geschichte die
sinnflut geschichte liest man bei
gigantisch steht haargenau das ist
wirklich 100 prozent abgeschrieben
aber ich habe gelernt ist ja legitim sie
sagen jetzt eben auch der bei jona hier
da kommt so schön vor eigentlich ich
habe gehört nicht mit großen
unterschieden jetzt wir haben also in
der abfolge judentum christentum islam
sind wir im siebten jahrhundert oder nun
langsam langsam
wir haben aber bitte bitte das ist nicht
gleich hier reden wir von drei
religionen islam ist keine religion
gerne in meine fragen geht woanders hin
wenn die abfolge text der sich sozusagen
wiederholen
der stoff aufgegriffen werden heißt das
aber auch wir wissen ja das erste
testament respektive das zweite oder nur
hier können wir nicht lesen ohne den
blick wie es ja ja auch das judentum auf
die heiligen schriften oder ein teil des
judentums heißt dass auch wir können den
koran eigentlich nicht lesen ohne den
blick auf die bibel über ihn natürlich
also für mich es gab mal sogar in der
geschichte der islamischen geschichte
eine wissenschaft an sicherheits
israelis amflora von israel weil das
wort israel kommt im koran 45 mal
übrigens also das wort weil die juden
kommen nicht als juden sie kommen die
sonne es reiche wie im alten testament
es gab eine wissenschaft zu studieren
und all diese stellen zu auszulegen und
deportieren warum so viel weil man
logischerweise hat
sich mit dem vorherigen prophetin
auseinandersetzen er hat er mit jesus
auseinandersetzen warum viel gewicht mit
moses warum hat er nur mit moos ist
auseinandergesetzt hat nur den ehe die
sonne israel muss an mich glauben er hat
nur mit ihnen gestalten und die christen
hat er zur seite
verschont und das ist absolut man kann
heute den koran nicht verstehen oder das
alter das wann haben sie denn die bibel
gelesen die bibel habe ich lange also
vor langer zeit wir sind aber jetzt
durch das buch habe ich noch mal gelesen
also noch mal vielleicht jetzt zum
zweiten mal gelesen aber das ist thema
was da gerade an schlagen ist natürlich
auch immer eines das ich sagen wir mal
eine nachfolgende generation die
nachfolgende religion muss sich ja den
altbestand sicherung das heißt sie muss
ja auf einem feld wachsen da da da der
althergebrachten beglaubigung und dann
die änderung vornehmen das ist im
christentum nicht anders das heißt die
idee die wurzel jeweils also das spät
folgenden christentum und islam ist
natürlich irgendwie immer eigentlich so
etwas wie die rückkehr zu den alten
beständen um die für sich fruchtbar zu
machen sie so auszulegen als hätten sie
sozusagen den rechten strang dann
entwickelt ja also das eigentliche
gefunden das ist ja überhaupt ihre ihre
daseinsberechtigung sonst könnten wir
lassen uns sonst hätte sie beim judentum
hätte ja gereicht ja also als als aber
beim alten testament zu erreichen können
also das ist glaube ich wirklich durch
zwang einer neuen religion gründung dass
sie sich der tradition versichern muss
indem sie sie für sich auch ein bisschen
umschreibt also sich darauf beruft
natürlich auch dinge erhält aber
zugleich natürlich abweichung vollzieht
was sonst kann es noch gar nicht geben
wenn wir schon dabei sind ist das auch
der grund warum die so streiten weil ich
kann doch sein judentum christentum
islam haben den gleichen stamm vater
beruhigt euch mal hier kommt aus der
gleichen erschöpft aus den gleichen
quellen nenne da wird weltweit
gestritten und gekämpft ja die streiten
weil interesse daran legen es gibt
übrigens streit warum nehmen sie die
drei religionen innerhalb der region
gibt es streit
die protestantin legen dem christentum
anders als als katholiken schiiten
anders als so nieten und bei den juden
genauso es gibt streit innerhalb der
religionen ich glaube das was man
einsehen soll also der catalis muss in
bayern von seehofer ist nicht der
catalis muss intensiver oder in
argentinien das ist anders
die differenzen der familie so weiter
aber der streit unter den zwischen den
verschiedenen familienmitglieder ist
diese abgrenzung mit ein grund war aber
nicht immer so heiß gekocht wie sie
heute wieder
man muss ja mal sagen dass die
islamische welt mahlzeit sehr sehr
friedfertig war in bezug auf tolerierung
von juden und christen ganz anders als
später die christen also wo die juden
und auch natürlich die idee koran
anhänger auf den scheiterhaufen landet
es gab eine friedliche zeit dass man
kann sagen für die damaligen
verhältnisse gesprochen eine sehr
tolerante zeit auch der islamischen welt
also geradezu mustergültig im vergleich
zu dem was er sonst los
man darf nicht vergessen das sind sie
sagen natürlich dass sie noch andere
ingredienzien oder mit macht und um etwa
ich sage wie die frage ist die
gesellschaft zuerst oder die religion
und für mich ist die gesellschaft zu ja
und dann die religion weil der islam ist
aber der regen ist nicht der islam ja
das ist das total also wenn wir heute
übrigens wir reden von islam in europa
alles wir hören von islam aber an sich
wir hören von nicht mal zwei prozent von
dem islam wie im grunde genommen was wir
islam sagen das ist der wahabismus also
wenn wir sagen frauen verschleierten wo
sind die frauen fächern der türkei erst
bei erdogan setzen sie ihren partner
mann der sind in saudi arabien frauen
dürfen keine autos fahren wo in istanbul
als sängerin einer verhärteten form des
islam wahabismus es gibt auch viele
muslimen muslime die nicht praktizieren
aber jetzt möchte ich noch zu einer
figur die sie hier auch haben maria und
fahren im hinblick dann auf jesus und da
interessiert uns vielleicht unsere
zuschauer haben er noch eine vorstellung
ist von nazareth mit dem neuen testament
wie spielt jesus von nazareth welche
rolle spielt einkochen jesus kuranyis
prophet und er wird immer erwähnt
september das heißt es da ist das wort
jesus der sohn mario wird das betont dem
koran nicht der sohn gottes maria
das ist das heißt gott hat maria
ausgewählt da sie ein speziellen sohn
sehr speziell hat ihm aus der welt er
wird diese botschaft haben gott das auf
der erde und das hat er gehabt also und
nachher deshalb prophet im jahr schon
kurz erwähnt er wird nicht gekreuzigt
lagerraum und er ist nicht gottes sohn
endet also erwähnt aber die kreuzigung
ist eines der wenigen ein jahr wenigen
wenn affen die außer biblische war
bezeugt sind wir wissen was sie es von
nazareth existiert hat und dass er
gekreuzigt wurde außer biblischen gene
und der koran sagt genauer werden obwohl
ja nicht geträumt
das ist genau wie die geschichte mit
ismael also bis x oder ist haken dann
kommt ein lamm oder wieder als hilfe und
dann wird das der sohn nicht geopfert
im falle von jesus letzter minute wird
aus versehen werden die römer judas also
gott verwandelt judas in der form von
jesus und warum wird gerettet wird zum
himmel holt mit den handel aufgenommen
schon vorstellen
gut das wird aber schon auch aber
gesetzlich aber das ist das heißt das
ist hier die lehrer die lehrer der
verräter der verräter judas weil der
vater es würde bestrafung der verbrechen
geschah gehört wird bestraft keiner darf
verraten da keiner dafür einbrechen wird
aber das heißt ein prophet darf nicht
den kreuzestod erleiden ist das der
grund und der grund aber da wie kann
gott erlauben und wer sich so nach dem
motto wie kann gott erlauben sein
prophet am auf kreuz zulegt damit
entschärft man die sache natürlich zur
unkenntlichkeit
weil immer eine dass das große
historische drama ja natürlich schon das
ist schon ein großer schwerthieb im
stachel des religiösen fleisches darf
man nicht vergessen und das rascheln
harmonieren na ja das hat das hat
natürlich eine zahl von sammer auf der
einen seite ein großes liebes begehren
hervorgerufen das weiß man ja von der
großen verehrung die dann auch maria
natürlich zu fällt besonders an
aber es hat natürlich auch immer die
widerspenstigen gegeben die das nicht
anerkannt haben und das also eigentlich
als schande sahen dass man also ein so
edelmann dass gott im preis gibt es
eigene sohn preisgegeben wird
und deswegen ist diese geschichte von
der dramatik her schwer zu überbieten
ja dass das ist ja auch das verlockende
daran dass sie eine unendlichen teppich
an interpretationen geburt war wieder
die schriftstellerin die ja wir können
auch sagen er ist einfach seine mission
bis zum ende gegangen oder das kann uns
nur raten das kann man so sagen aber was
bringt trockene theologie und ich meine
allein die die vorstellung ich meine es
ist ein wirklich ein grausamer tod den
er viele erlebten haben kreuzigung wagen
gebe aber aber hey ich meine dass das
das ganze also prozedere ist der absolut
hinreißend also mit diesem kreuz mit
diesem schweren balken irgendwie noch
durch die durch jerusalem zur eigenen
firma bisher abgenommen dann dann also
jedes detail der man sieht ja die filme
oder heraus entstand ist wirklich ja die
sind wirklich also jetzt vielleicht
einigen diese grauenhafte also dass der
plot ist es ist aber schon wirkmächtig
und er hat natürlich auch was mir dann
wirklich gut gefällt was mich also
sakrisch berührt geradezu ist eigentlich
das in kommen zu anja das heißt also das
ist gottes genauso wie das ist ein
bisschen die die fortsetzung von abra
haben auch in großform das heißt es in
konsole ist doch im grunde den eigenen
sohn schlachten zu sorgen das ist doch
im kommen so raabe ja und das gleiche
gilt ja bei der jesu englischen
geschichte eigentlich auch das heißt das
ist eine ein riesiges dilemma das aber
meines erachtens ein großartiges
ergebnis gezeigt hat da verweise ich
gerne auf den auf den philosophen rennen
der wirklich ein großartiges jesus buch
geschrieben hat ganz große klasse
in dem er eigentlich versucht
nachvollziehen dass durch die kreuzigung
durch den schmachvollen entsetzlichen
tod eines gänzlich unschuldigen menschen
das also er sieht ihn gar nicht als
gutes omen also einen gänzlich
unschuldigen menschen so etwas wie die
abkehr von von formen das opfer rituals
unter tötung von menschen zu rein
menschlichen zwecken ein großes formal
selbst und das sehe ich auch so
das heißt und für diese interpretation
muss man nicht mehr religiös sein
sondern das ist wirklich es ist wirklich
eine sagenhafte geschichte dass ein
zutiefst unschuldiger mensch grausam
getötet wird alle dafür das noch hin zu
sagen als letzte das natürlich die
mythologischen opfer alle schuldig sind
ja gehen dann in der mythologischen
zeiten geschlachtet werden mal irgendwas
auf dem kerbholz
ich wollte nur noch anfügen es gibt hier
wie bei isaac und abraham gibt es auch
natürlich die sogenannte nicht
offizielle interpretation dh es gibt
einen ganzen strang und theologie in
tirol und extrem dagegen wäre neben
gegen diese opfer theologie aber dies
nur als nachtrag wie wir das sonst
dargestellt jetzt von rath zeit nimmt
geht als wunderheiler durch durch die
gegend wie ein vergleich und wurden dann
die gleichen wunder also dass heißt es
eine große große total großer für die
die treten alle anderen zwei propheten
auch so man nennen sie die buch besitzer
erhält getan
der koran erwischt er weiß ihnen respekt
die beiden muss sowohl moses als auch
jesus so tolle respekt weil für muhammad
war so also das heißt gott hat die
religion wie ein menschen behandeln also
die menschheit das gibt drei phasen in
dem im leben der menschheit erstmal
judentum als der mensch noch kind war
bis in die kindheit der menschheit und
dann die priorität
das christentum und reife ist es ist ja
man muss wie du gesagt hast man muss
irgendwie anders interpretiert damit man
das legitimieren
nur eine sache die ich auch im buch
erwähnt habe keine geht auf die zeit vor
der vor der religion wo die bücher
deshalb für mich als gratis interessant
wenn ich sage die meisten geschichten
die im alten testament entstanden sind
oder geschrieben wurden sind sind von
den priester der von den juden die in
gefangenschaft waren im babylon und in
asse und nur sind wir weiterhin thema
der überhöhung der eigenen kultur oder
religion zurück gibt es eben heute wie
sie die sich an einen tisch setzen und
aus verschiedenen blickwinkeln und auch
aus verschiedenen religionen das
miteinander anschauen wir sind am ende
unseres gesprächs noch ganz kurz was
bleibt von ihrem projekt das weiß ich
jetzt nicht da geht s weiter als
beantworten wir werden jetzt nicht
reihenweise bücher zusammen schreiben
weil das ist nur ein thema das uns beide
fasziniert hat also ich könnte jetzt
keine nicht eigentlich einklinken in
einem roman über saudi arabien und er
sich auch nicht eine überdeckelung also
da trennen sich die wege wieder aber es
war eine schöne sache
also ich habe attentat auf sie aber das
weiß sie nicht man kommt ja wir sind
sehr gespannt sie haben auch nicht nein
gesagt
er weiß auch davon nicht wir sind sehr
gespannt ganze dank in beiden
ortschaften war für dieses gespräch
heißt und dank kein klinisch jetzt
gleich wiederholen wir das gespräch
meines kollegen bussard mit dem wohl
bedeutendsten schriftsteller israels
amos oz
[Musik]